[Música]
con una banda sonora de estruendosos
aplausos y fuertes ovaciones el líder de
corea del norte kim jong-un anunció lo
que según los medios estatales es un
milagro sin precedentes además tres
meses después de que ordenara la máxima
emergencia por un brote de omicron en
pyongyang and one young world declaró
solemnemente la victoria en el
exterminio de nuevo coronavirus que
había hecho incursiones en nuestro
territorio
iván y la protección de la vida y la
salud del pueblo miller sentía smart son
familia
al parecer kim jong-un experimentó la
enfermedad de primera mano su hermana
kim jong dijo que el líder norcoreano
enfermó con lo que ella llamó fiebre una
palabra que el país usa para describir
el coronavirus young culpó de la
propagación del cob y 19 a los folletos
de propaganda que fueron volados sobre
la frontera que el país comparte con
corea del sur una medida que advirtió
provocar a represalias mortales según
negó dichas afirmaciones con wii el
gobierno informa que no hay posibilidad
de que el virus entre en el norte a
través de folletos enviados desde
nuestro lado lo publican más céntricas
tura la supuesta erradicación del cob y
19 en corea del norte supone un respiro
para el aislado país cuyo pobre sistema
sanitario no podría soportar un brote
importante hasta mayo el país había
negado fervientemente haber registrado
casos del virus durante los dos primeros
años de la pandemia ahora ha registrado
casi 48 millones de infecciones de la
llamada fiebre y sólo 74 muertes además
no se han reportado nuevos casos desde
el 29 de julio la organización mundial
de la salud desconfía de estas cifras el
mes pasado afirmó que la situación en
corea del norte estaba empeorando no
mejorando